c'est tout ils ont évacué très
rapidement ils ont les dents sorties
pendant une heure le temps que tout est
sécuritaire
c'est sûr qu'ils s'excusent très faible
mais n'ont pu rien faire je pense qu'on
fait de la bonne affaire juste faire
sortir sans nous rien dire pour le
moment puis ensuite vous informer de la
situation
ça fait pas quand même c'est quand même
des frayeurs 64 établissements scolaires
visé par un courriel qui a été envoyé
aux petites heures du matin 1h du matin
très précisément à la plupart des
institutions courriel ou un groupe qui
se fait appeler le sceptre roue jeudi un
groupe mais mettez des guynemer à tout
ça le sceptre rouge qui en veut aux
professeurs à cause des moyens de
pression à cause des grèves est dit
résultat on va mettre des bombes dans
quatre endroits et il a ça continue puis
je vous passe les détails avec nous
françois dauré policier à la retraite la
sortie du québec monsieur doré quand on
lit tout le corps hier on se dit une
source c'est pas sérieux c'est n'importe
quoi mais on le disait plus tous les
policiers les établissements scolaires
n'ont pas le choix ils n'ont pas le
choix que de faire une vérification ni
mal la possibilité justement de cette
menace là est ce qu'elle peut être mise
à exécution si c'est le cas font réagir
minimalement voyager faire des
vérifications des évacuations besoin non
il faut pas engendrer un sentiment de
panique mais on veut faire peur et ça
c'est sûr donc vous êtes directeur
d'école vous recevez ce iman là vous
savez ce courriel à vous ordonné une
évacuation
il est possible si le courriel est
adressée à l'école où je suis il est
fort probable que oui je vais demander
une évacuation
parce qu'il appartient la direction
d'école la direction d'établissement
d'ordonner cette évacuation d'un des
policiers peuvent de suggérer peuvent le
recommander mais il appartient la
direction d'établissement de prendre un
décision
le problème c'est que dans le dans la
lettre on parle de plusieurs jours
jusqu'à vendredi
non on ne peut pas paralyser un système
d'enseignement
on a fouillé aujourd'hui oui et tout ce
qu on a fouillé on aurait évidemment
rien trouvé
donc est ce qu'on considère que la
menace élevée sans que la menace soit
levé la menace s'étend sur quatre jours
il semble y avoir une forme d'ultimatum
jules dit on dit que si et là on utilise
un terme évidemment un anglicisme ci a
pas de terreau mination on va commencer
en prendre directement aux syndicats et
on va continuer à s'en prendre aux
écoles donc ça semble être un ultimatum
non lagarde n'est pas mais c'est oui les
fouilles ont été fait et ce qu'il va y
avoir plus de surveillance au cours des
prochains jours
bien sûr tout de rien ce qu'on va
retrouver la personne qui a envoyé cette
nuit est ce qu'il ya des bonnes chances
qu'on retrouve cette personne je le
souhaite je le souhaite les moyens
techniques dont disposent les autorités
ne sont pas comparables aux services
m'ont d'espionnage que sont la cia et la
nsa ou même peut-être les crs par contre
les policiers seraient affectés la
cybercriminalité ont des moyens
techniques ont de l'expérience
oui une combinaison de moyens moyens
dans la quête pourrait arriver justement
trouvé qui la personne les deux sont des
personnes responsables maison parce que
selon les informations la key qui fuit
qui colle on n'a rien on n'a pas
d'indicé on ne sait pas même où chercher
à ce moment ci certainement des sites
d'anonymisation qui ont été utilisés
pour justement perdre s'ils ont vu la
très électronique du courriel
par quel serveur à quelle adresse ip
quels fournisseurs d'accès internet et
tout ça s'est vérifié par les policiers
qui vont mettre tous les moyens dont il
dispose
oui vont collaborer vont parler avec
leurs collègues la grc spvm pour mettre
en commun des ressources quand doit-on
prendre au sérieux ou non une menace à
la bombe parce que beaucoup beaucoup
d'organismes qui reçoivent des appels
des menaces à la bresse que dans votre
expérience à chaque fois qu'elle menace
à la bombe ont fait comme s'ils avaient
un bon ben c'est qu'on peut pas se
permettre une évaluation de la menace et
ont ce propos on peut pas se permettre
d'ignorer cette monnaie cela est ce
qu'elle est plausible encore une fois
est-ce qu'elle est réalisable
est ce qui est possible d'exécuter cette
monnaie cela si la réponse est oui et
c'est automatique il ya des gestes à
poser les gestes évidemment de
vérification d'évacuation besoin de
fouilles de mettre le personnel sur le
terrain pour pouvoir faire ses fruits là
on peut pas se permettre des
descartes et c'est si on retrouve
l'individu puel on imagine peut-être
quelqu'un dans son sous-sol la
boutonneux qui complètement dérangé peu
importe si on leur trouve c'est très
grave s'expose
c'est un crime très grave qui va faire
absolument c'est une arrestation ce sont
des accusations en vertu du code
criminel méfait public est encore une
fois en vain le ministre moreau en a
fait mention
est-ce que des espèces y terrorisme sans
aucune foi ne s'est encore une fois allé
trop loin
mais faire peur a engendré la parfaire
créant des menaces de blessure ou demain
c'est ce qu'on fait ici et c'est très
grave je le remercie beaucoup
je vous en prie allah prochain roman